Let's take a quick look at how we would use
Device Motion to implement another common mechanism, the shape to send
feedback feature. Detecting a shape is actually pretty easy, we
just register an event listener for device motion and inside are
event handler. We calculate the squares of all of the
accelarations in all three directions And then test to see how
big that absolute sum is. If we get a large value
here, we know we've hit a shake, so we can demonstrate
that on the screen. If we wanted to be fancy, we might want to
sum these values over an interval of time, so slower motion that goes on
for longer would still trigger it, or we might want to add rotation into
the sum. But in practice this will work pretty well. Let's take a look.